I, uh, I'm a big fan of your
work. I've read much of your work.
I've seen many of your interviews
and videos online. And, uh,
one of the things that I really wanted
to talk to you about it I find quite
interesting is consciousness and your
belief that consciousness is not simply
calculation, but that there's
something more to it and what,
what you think this more could possibly
be from a scientific perspective,
which is unusual because a lot of people
have some theories about consciousness,
but they're usually crazy
people like myself. Well,
I mean, we were all conscious and so
we may have theories about it. Yeah.
But now the ideas came by a
somewhat round about route.
Uh, I, I went to Cambridge
to do graduate work.
It was mathematics. I was working on
pure mathematical subjects, Algebra,
geometry. But I thought, you
know, we've got three years.
I'll spend some of the time going to
other talks that might be interesting.
So I went to three talks particularly,
which had a big influence on me.
One was taught by Herman
Bondi with, uh, um,
general relativity cosmology,
wonderful tour.
We're very sort of animated presentation,
the ad and then there
was a talk by Paul Dirac,
one of the founders of quantum mechanics
and HIStalk what he's completely
wonderful talk to
wonderful lectures as well,
but in a completely different style.
He was very quiet and precise in
what he said and everything. Anyway,
in the very first lecture he was talking
about the superposition principle in
quantum mechanics.
So if you have a particle and it could
be in one spot or it could be in another
spot, then you have all sorts of states
where it can be in both places at once.
That's sort of strange,
but you got to get used to that idea and
he illustrated with his speech a piece
of chalk and I think he broke it in two
to illustrate it could be in one spot or
in the other. And my mind sort
of wondered at that point,
I didn't know what I was thinking about,
but I wasn't concentrating.
And about a few minutes
later he'd finished,
his description is explanation and I
had some vague memory of something about
energy,
but I didn't understand what he said.
And I've been totally mystified
by this ever since. So I,
I suppose if I had heard what he said,
he would have said something to calm me
down and I sort of accepted in one way
or another. But as it was, it
seemed to me this was a major issue.
How on earth do you have things that
don't behave according to what quantum
mechanics says? Like cricket balls and
baseballs and things like that. Anyway,
that's two of the talks.
The other course was a course
by a man called Stephen,
who talked on mathematical logic and he
explained things like girdle's theorem
and touring machines during machines
being the mathematical notion upon which
modern computers are based or
computers basically. And uh,
uh, the thing about good will
stay. Let me see. I'd heard,
I used to have a colleague when I was
undergraduate in Percival who also became
a scientist's later on.
And we talked about, uh,
logic and you know, how you could make
this kind of mathematical systems,
which worked out logic.
And I'd heard about this girls and which
seemed to say that there were things in
mathematics that you just couldn't prove.
And I didn't like that idea,
but I,
when I heard the,
when I went to this course by Steen and
he explained what it really says and
what it says, it's suppose you've got a
method of proving things in mathematics.
And when I say things,
I mean things with numbers.
That one famous example is
fair Mars last year, um, uh,
there's the Gold Goldberg conjecture,
which isn't yet proved that they every
even number bigger than two is the sum of
two prime numbers.
This the sort of example of the thing,
it's just sort of mathematical
things about numbers,
which you can see what they mean.
Uh,
but it may be very difficult to
see whether it's true or untrue.
But the idea it often is in mathematics,
you've got a system of methods of proof.
And the key thing about these methods
of proof is that you can have a computer
check whether you've done it right.
So you, these rules, you know,
they could be adding in B,
it's the same as BNA and things like that.
And you, um, if you give
you say to the computer,
say, here's a theory,
I'm like Goldbar conjecture and you see
whether it can be proved and you say,
maybe I've got a proof and this follows
these steps and you give it to the
computer and it says, Yep,
you've done it right. It's true.
Or maybe it will say you've
done it right and it's not true.
Or it may not see anything
but just go on forever.
But these are the sort of outcomes.
And the point about it is that if you
believe that these procedures do give you
a proof, in other words, that if
the algorithm says, yeah, it's true,
then you believe that it is true because
you've understood the, all the rules.
He looked at the first one,
so yeah, that's okay. You
look at the second one says,
mom. Oh yeah, I see. Okay, that's great.
And you go all the way down and as long
as you convinced all those rules work
and if it says yes, that's
something you believe. Okay,
now what girl shows as he
constructs a very specific sentence,
a statement which is a number
thing like like the fair,
most lost their arm or something.
I think about numbers, which
what he shows is if you trust this
algorithm for proving mathematical things,
then you can see by the way
it's constructed that it's true,
but you can also see by the way it's
constructed that it cannot be proved by
this procedure.
Now,
this was amazing to me because
it tells me that, okay,
you cannot formalize your understanding
in a scheme which you could put on a
computer that you see.
This statement which got will comes up
with is something you can see on the
basis of the same understanding that
allows you to trust the rules that it's
true, but that is not actually
derives bubble by the rules.
It you see, it's true by virtue
of your belief in the rules.
And this to me was amazing and
I thought, Golly, you know,
what's understanding,
what does it mean?
Is it something following rules?
This is an algorithm.
Well this more or less says it's not
an algorithm because whenever it was,
there will be something that you could
still see his true even though you don't
get it through the algorithm
that you had in the first place.
So this was a lot of
subtleties about this too,
which people argue about endlessly.
But it was pretty convincing to me that
the shows that we don't think when we
understand something that what's going
on in our heads is not an algorithm.
It's not following rules,
it's something else.
It's something that requires our conscious
appreciation of what we're thinking
about.
I'm thinking it's a conscious thing and
understanding is a conscious activity.
So I formed the view that conscious
activities, whatever they are,
not just that kind of thing,
but you know,
playing music or we're falling in love
or whatever these things might be on,
not computations. There's something
else going on. And then I thought,
because I like to think myself as a
scientist and I think that what's going in
our heads is according to the laws
of physics and these laws of physics,
um,
pretty good.
They seem to work well in the outside
world and so I believe that the laws that
work in our heads are the same as those
laws. So I began to think about it, well,
what about Newton's mechanics?
But you could put that on a computer.
What about Einstein's special relativity?
You could do that.
What about Maxwell's
was wonderful equations,
which tell you how less electricity and
magnetism operates and lights and the
radio waves and all these things.
That's all follows this beautiful set
of equations that Max will produced.
You can put that on a computer.
Okay.
Then you may have to worry
about approximations and
these depend on continuous
numbers rather than discreet things,
but I didn't think that's the answer.
Then I thought,
what about general relativity and Stein's
theory of gravity with cove space and
all that, where you were familiar
now with Lego, this detector,
which is detected black hole spiraling
into each other from distant galaxy and
how do we know that those signals
are black holes, but well,
because of the calculations,
people who put this thing on an algorithm
and you know what those signals look
like.
So Einstein's general relativity,
sure you can put that in a cubicle on the
computer. What about quantum mechanics?
Well, there's the famous
equation of Schrodinger,
which tells you how a
quantum state evolves.
You could put that on a computer too.
It's difficult in many ways.
There's many more parameters
you have to worry about,
but it's just as comfortable as
these other things. Well, you see,
I then remembered directs lecture.
You see and how it is that these things
that work in the quantum world don't
seem to work at the level
of classical big things.
And it all depends on this process of
what's called measurement in quantum
mechanics. And the measurement process
is something you learn how to do,
but it's not the Schrodinger equation.
It's something else. And Schroeder,
he himself was very intrigued by
this fact that his own equation,
it gives you nonsense and you put the
famous Schrodinger's cat where he produces
a situation in which the cat would
be dead and alive at the same time.
He produced that in example simply
to demonstrate that roughly speaking,
his equation gives you nonsense
under these circumstances.
So there's something else
and the something else goes
beyond our current quantum
mechanics.
And it tells you what happens when the
quantum state makes a decision between,
doesn't follow the Schrodinger and
does one thing or the other. No,
everybody knows that who does quantum
mechanics, but they think, oh,
it's what's called making a measurement
and you're allowed to do something
different.
But that didn't make sense to me.
And so I had the view that,
okay,
there is a big gap and our understanding
and if there's something in the world
which isn't something you could put
on a computer, that's where it is.
So the view,
I've held that for a long time and uh,
that there's something non computable,
something beyond computation involved
in our understandings of things.
So that's a view of health for ages.
I didn't do much with it.
I just held the view until,
I think there was a radio talk between
Marvin Minsky and Edward Fred kin and
they were explaining about what computers
can do. And they were talking about,
okay,
you have a computer,
two computers talking to each other over
there and you walk up to the room and
the time you've walked up the room to the
computers, they have computed, commuted,
communicates with each other more thoughts
than the human race ever has done.
You see? And I thought, well,
I see where you're coming from,
but I don't think that's what's
happening in, in human communication.
Human understanding is something
different from what computers do.
And consciousness is the key thing.
Consciousness is something different
from computation. So I've held that view.
But then when I heard this talk by
Minsky and um, and Fred skin, I thought,
well,
I had ideas of writing a book some time.
In a long time in the future when I'm
retired, this is some while back, I said,
and I thought, well, maybe
this gives you the focus.
And so I wrote this book
called the emperor's new mind,
which was supposed to be
saying, well, you know, we,
everybody seems to be thinking one thing,
but yeah,
the little kid notices that the emperor
doesn't have any clothes. So it was the,
uh, that theme of that story,
which was the basis of the book.
So I say, okay, maybe a lots of people
think that all we're doing is computing,
but if you stand back and you say, well,
no, there's something else going on.
So that was the basis of my
thoughts about consciousness.
But I wrote this book thinking that by
the time I got to the end of the book,
you see, it was mostly about physics
and mathematics and things like that.
But I was really aiming for this thing
about what's going on in conscious
thinking. And I thought, well, I'll learn
a bit about neurophysiology and so on.
And by the time I get to
the end of the book, uh,
know pretty well what it could be.
I didn't got to the end of the book and
I just sort of tapered off rather than
with something a little bit unbelievable.
And that was the end. Now you see,
I hope that this book would stimulate
young people to get interested in science
and that sort of thing, that
mathematics. And that was fine.
And when the book was published,
I didn't get letters from young kids.
I got letters from old retired people who,
the ones who had the time to read my book.
Okay,
well that was a little disappointing,
but okay,
I'm glad the old retired
people like my book.
But the other thing was I got a letter
from the Stuart Hameroff and this letter
said more or less,
I think you don't appreciate that there's
something else going on. Not Neurons.
I mean the neurons,
I could see you couldn't isolate
the quantum effects that the,
you get the what's called an environmental
decoherence will happen and you get
no way of keeping the quantum state to
the level that you need in this picture.
So I really,
I didn't have it,
but Stuart Hameroff pointed out to me
these little things called microtubules
and he'd built up a theory that
microtubules are absolutely fundamental.
The consciousness.
He had his own reasons for believing that
I had never heard of them at that time,
but then I checked up,
you know,
I get lots of letters from people who
maybe don't make sense sometimes the
letters and this one I thought,
well this is another one.
I realized these microtubules are there
and they looked like just the kind of
thing that could well be supporting the
kind of level of quantum mechanics up to
a level where you could expect the
the quantum state to sort of collapse.
That's the terminology. People using
quantum mechanics microtubules,
they are inside brain neurons.
The R and D,
and this is a recent discovery for them.
They're actually in lots of cells.
You see, people often complain,
oh, they're in your liver too,
not just your brain and your
liver conscious and all that.
But this has to do with the organization
of them and the nature of them,
the particular kind of microtubules,
how they're, how they're arranged,
which is different in the brain.
How does it vary in the brain
compared to other cells?
I think one big difference, so they're
not Stewart emphasizes, there's so much,
there are two kinds of microtubules.
They're the ones who have a lattice
[inaudible] lattice and the a lattice ones
are the very symmetrical ones.
There are tubes and they look
the same all the way around.
They've got a very beautiful arrangement
of these proteins called Tubulin and
they make a very nice arrangement,
which is connected with Fibonacci
numbers and things like that.
So they look a bit like for cones,
but there were powerful. They're not,
they don't taper off. But, um,
the thing is in the brain,
I think most of microtubules are
probably what to call lattice ones.
And they're don't have so much symmetry.
They've got like a sort of seemed on the
one side and they're very important in
transporting some substances
around cells and so on.
And Microsoft was all sorts of things.
They don't just do what,
what Stuart and I think they
may be doing in the brain.
So the idea is that in the brain they're
organized differently and probably the
ones that are important have a lattice
ones, which are the very symmetrical ones.
And for a long time people
couldn't see the difference and um,
cause they look very similar.
Um,
and they may well be the ones that
happened to be in pyramidal cells as a
particular kind of cell. So, you know,
one of the things I'm interested in me
a lot is how it is that not all parts of
the brain are the same in this respect
is that you've got the cerebrum,
this is the part at the top and you know,
divided down the middle on that.
When you see brains, that's what you
normally see with the convolutions in,
in the,
in it,
but right underneath and at the back
there's a thing called the cerebellum,
which more it looks more like a,
like a ball of wool or something.
And the Cerebellum, I don't, it
may still be argument about this,
but it seems to be that it's completely
unconscious and it has comparable number
of neurons, far more connections
between neurons and the cerebrum.
And it's what takes control.
And maybe when you're driving your car
and you're thinking about something else
and you,
you don't,
you're not thinking what you're doing
because it's unconscious and the
unconscious control,
you know,
pianist is very expert and moves the
fingers around and plays a note with a
little finger. That pns
doesn't think, well,
I've got to move that muscle this way
and this mountain that way and so on.
And it's,
it's all controlled unconsciously in a
lot of this unconscious control is done
somewhere else in the cerebellum when
you, when you get really skilled. So, uh,
it seemed to me,
okay,
you've got different kinds of structures
different and it could well be that
these pyramidal cells,
which have a particular organization
of microtubules are the ones that were,
that consciousness is really coming,
coming to light mainly, I don't know.
There's a lot which is,
which is not known about this
controversial and all sorts of things,
but the cerebellum seems to be
different and organized differently.
So it's not just how many neurons,
how many connections are there because
there are more in the cerebellum.
So it's not that saying else.
Do they know this from observing the
brain through Fmr rye or something like
that during particular activities?
I don't know.
I would imagine partly just examining
it went from dead people and looking at
brains and trying to estimate how
many neurons their own it. Right.
But how would they know what, which
part? Partial, which is consciousness.
I don't know that they do know
that. Well I guess. But the co,
the Cerebellum,
there was a bit of an argument about that.
I thought whether it's
completely unconscious or not,
but it seems that actions that are
carried out by the Cerebellum, you don't,
you're not aware of what you're
doing. But I mean it's, you know,
if he had a tennis player who has to
think very carefully about where that w
with tilt the ball now the
control of what you're doing.
So the overall control,
it's probably done with the cerebrum,
but the cerebellum is
controlling the detailed motions,
how the fingers move and
all that kind of thing.
And then you'd make
sure that if you play a,
thinks it's going to hit the ball down,
down the line there. And then the,
the rest is done under the control
of an unconscious procedure.
I mean, I may be simplifying, but you're
saying, so you're saying that there's,
we don't totally understand,
but we know that there's different parts
of the brain that are responsible for
different activities and some activities
don't seem to be conscious. Yes, yes.
And I think it's probably the case.
No, I'm, I'm maybe, I don't know.
I shouldn't make a statement
and I don't really know.
But certainly there are lots of different
parts of the cerebrum which maybe,
which maybe not conscious too,
so I'm not saying that the whole thing
is capable of being conscious. It's,
they seem to be differences
in different parts.
But are you convinced that microtubules
are responsible for consciousness or its
primary theory?
I think they're the one of the
best candidates. I you see,
I don't think it's only microtia.
I Dunno.
I'm not sure what Stuart
Hameroff sphere on this is.
He certainly thinks the microchip was
exceedingly important in consciousness and
I think he's right.
That's the feeling I get.
And he's done a lot of work on trying
to find a what? Anesthetic gases.
It's an important,
one of the important ways you can tell
things about conscious and most of it you
can't. It's just hearsay.
And what does it vary? It is,
but one of the important ways you can
tell something about consciousness is
turns it off in a reversible way.
In Stuart's job is,
do you know he's an anesthesiologist?
He puts people to sleep well.
I think he would complain if I say putting
it to sleep because under anesthetic
is actually different for sleep.
But you make them unconscious
in a reversible way. You
want to make sure thank,
you can wake them up again.
And a,
it's obviously a very skills thing,
but I guess a lot of his colleagues might
be a skilled at doing it, but don't.
They asked the questions about what
they're actually doing from the point of
view of the biology and
the physics and so on.
So still it was really
interested in that question.
Partly I think the thing is like,
oh my tosas cell division and he was very
struck by the way that the chromosomes
or lion lion up and that there's these
microtubules which pulling them and
they're really a big part in, in, in,
in the structure of cells and how they,
how they behave and so on. But
why they are consciousness. Well,
I guess it was an experience with,
with um,
putting people under anesthetics and the
fact that the gases which puts you to
sleep. And there, again, I
shouldn't say to sleep, but
put you on the anesthetic. I,
I'm very unconnected chemically.
They're different kinds of things be yet
they still seem to have the same effect
and to understand what it is
that they affect is, you know,
there's a lot of his
interest is to do with that.
So just by putting someone unconscious
and registering what parts of the brain
are no longer active,
this is what they're using to sort of
reverse engineered by turning those parts
on. That's what enables
consciousness. Was this the, well,
I think it's probably a simplification
of what, what's going, but that's,
that's a good, uh, first first step. Yes.